for years people have been asking valve
when's left 4 dead 3 coming out when's
life for dead 3 coming out i've been
asking
when left 4 dead 3 is coming out well
turns out the original devs for
left 4 dead decided to make their own
version of left 4 dead 3 called
back for blood uh me and phil hornshaw
here
got a chance to check out some of the uh
closed alpha for the game
and yeah phil how much is this game just
left for dead yeah it's been a long time
since i played left 4 dead
this feels like i fell right back into
it
from back in the days of the orange box
whatever um you know i
it feels great but it also feels very
very familiar
yeah no i i certainly wouldn't say
that's a bad thing at least for me
personally i feel like
there hasn't been a game that's quite
hit the itch that left 4 dead
had so like seeing seeing the way this
game is just like
the the way it feels the way it's
structured it's like yup you're going
through these
uh kind of like scripted levels there's
four different sections for each one
you have your primary weapon your
secondary weapon melee weapons are a
thing
uh the hordes function very much the
same um
i think it still has a director right
like it kind of uses that ai
this feels very much more action focused
to me than i think
original left 4 dead did uh you're still
doing things like
avoiding um interacting with certain
things that might draw the horde on you
and stuff like that but this is a game
that um
turtle rock has is doing the zombie
apocalypse but it's
deeper in right like so instead of being
a survivor in the outbreak
like in left 4 dead it's been about a
year you've got an established
um settlement i think it's called fort
hope
and uh these are like the badasses who
have
survived the zombie apocalypse and are
established
and so you're kind of out there like
knowing what you're doing you're better
at this
than maybe the characters in left 4 dead
were and
you you know how to live in the zombie
apocalypse so it's still
very much you know running from hordes
and trying not to die and the world is
all against you
but you're a stronger group of
characters who are a little more capable
and you're kind of waging war against
the zombies more
than maybe in left 4 dead and it does
that thing that uh the original left 4
deads did which i liked where a lot of
that comes in through
character dialogue context clues writing
on the wall it does all that stuff
um like left 4 dead i i really like the
characters so far they have very strong
personalities and they're
they banter off of each other so it's
it's hitting all those
those same feelings
let's do this before i change my mind
well let's get into
what this game does do differently right
the main thing being
its card system yeah so it feels like
turtle rock has pulled a lot from left 4
dead
originally and then kind of merged in
some of the things that it learned from
its other big asymmetrical multiplayer
game um evolve
right so you've got this card system and
you earn cards as you played you unlock
them
uh over time and you build out what is
called a deck
you know like a card deck before each
mission
that you play and the cards are all like
different perks right
so as you run a mission at the at the
start
you have a deck of say 15 cards you get
to pick i think three
that are sort of randomly given to you
um as a series of choices like you get a
hand of three cards and you get to pick
one and then you
uh assign three to your character at the
start and they kind of tweak
how you will play the game right so like
you might get
more effective meds or the ability to
sprint and shoot at the same time
or you know any number of other perks
and so you're creating a deck that's
kind of tuned to your play style that
will give you
a bunch of cool little perks along the
way
um and you use those to like
make yourself a better co-op player and
to give yourself more abilities
and you know to like amp up the action
so the big metagame part of
uh back for blood is going to be running
these missions over and over again
with all these different cards at your
disposal and trying to earn better cards
so that it kind of adds this more
replayability factor to
the left at formula because it's still
using a lot of those same
ideas you're still playing the same
mission but it'll have like that
director
id uh like ai that's kind of controlling
things and changing up
the way the scenario is so you won't
face the same run every time you go
and then your aspect of that the way
you're customizing
your playthrough is with those cards and
kind of leaning into your teamwork
aspect i need to spend more time with it
to determine
uh how impactful the cards are or like
how it you know is it possible to break
the game with that stuff but at least so
far
it seems like it's just tweaks
that kind of just like give you a little
edge and like you said it's it's almost
like
uh you can kind of build like a class
without having like a proper class
system
and you can build like multiple decks
and you can you sort of have these
presets so
like you said you can kind of go in
knowing like okay i'm playing with my
friends and and i'm gonna build
a deck that kind of emphasizes healing
right or giving people like
support stuff uh and i i like also how
it is
reactive where in between rounds you'll
see the director is like okay i put the
director puts down this card
that changes the horde for this section
yeah and you can kind of be like okay
we need to respond to that i have this
card that i got pulled i should put that
down
and that'll hopefully give us an
advantage um
i i yeah i need to spend more time with
it but at least so far it feels like it
it keeps the game fresh which was
admittedly a thing that i do think
eventually got stale about left 4 dead
is was once you mastered those maps
it's sort of like you know the best way
to go through right those maps
and and having the card stuff tweaks the
game enough
without at least so far feeling like
oh i can just like optimize and like
break the game with my specific deck
yeah like cards aren't that powerful
yeah it didn't seem like
i messed around building a deck um this
morning when we ran through
and it didn't feel like the cards like
may give you that much of a match of any
sort but they do give you like little
tweaks that make you more useful like i
had a perk card that
allowed me to find more weapons and to
get weapons with greater frequency so
like they're a little easier to spot in
the map
we ran past a bunch when you and i
played right so like it's not easy to
find weapons necessarily
they're all over the place but it's very
easy to blow past them in a
combat scenario or whatever this perk
made it so i was finding more weapons
and um and that they were easier they
like pinged on my
hud a little better too so i like i i
was able to add utility to the team
by helping them find better gear it's
stuff like that a lot of the time
there's another one where
if one of your characters goes down
everybody else gets healed
like 45 points over 10 seconds which
is super useful like we we got a lot of
utility out of that one
um it didn't save us we lost a number of
times but
but it definitely was helpful to like
you know when you're running into a
horde of zombies trying to save your
teammate
you get that little extra boost and
what's cool about
the perk cards is that some of them are
for the whole team some of them are just
for you but they do kind of like
help you build out your team a little
better and when i was talking to the
turtle rock devs
something they said was that they were
trying to focus more on
making the cooperative play feel better
regardless of whether
you put in a lot of time right so you
want to be able to play the game
if you've got a thousand hours in and
you want to play with your teammate or
or friend or whatever who's got like two
hours you don't want them to be an
anchor that you're dragging through
the match right because they haven't
they don't have the experience
this card system is kind of geared
toward making it so that everybody can
have fun
and that you're still useful without
necessarily having to
dump a huge amount of time into the game
like you get you do get rewarded for
playing and you do get cooler cards
but they don't make you like super op or
create a situation in which you don't
want to play with anybody who doesn't
have those cards or anything like that
the other thing you mentioned was
weapons which is also a pretty big
change from left 4 dead in that
weapons now have attachments yeah that
you can uh find sometimes you'll find a
weapon with attachment
other times you will buy attachments at
the safe houses using uh
the game's crate and currency system so
far it seems pretty
scarce so you really have to make a
choice between like do i want to get
this health pack or do i want to get
an attachment so far it feels like
compared to
previous left or dead where you would
like kind of find the weapon of your
choice or you'd constantly be kind of
changing out weapons
you really want to like stick with a
particular weapon that you feel good
with
and like really deck that one out with
the attachments
yeah uh at least so far i
i do enjoy that system i i feel like it
it encourages you to yeah like i said
just like stick with that particular
weapon and find
find that that role and kind of stick
with it right
yeah i do think it's like one gearing
toward
having you provide a specific utility to
the team so that you guys can all work
together
and two rewarding you for playing well
right in any given run like so the last
couple runs that i've done
i spent a lot more time just like
looking around and you find
the in-game currency it's called copper
kind of all over the place depending on
the difficulty and that sort of thing
and the way the director is tuning the
level to try to help you or hinder you
but um yeah so you can find a lot of
money and the way it works i think
is that any character can pick up money
and then everybody gets that money into
their
like pocket so if i find 25 copper
everybody gets 25 copper but when you
buy stuff
it's your particular amount of money and
you're also rewarded with money
um when you finish the match the more
people who survive
um an act and get to the safe room at
the end the more money you get at the
end and then you can buy stuff from that
crate
uh in the safe room at the beginning of
each one so you can like grab new health
items or whatever
there are also things you can find and
buy out in the world
if you look around i found a couple
places where if you've got like i think
it's about a thousand
copper you can sometimes find a little
dossier that's got a perk card
that's either um a set card or a
randomized one that you can just like
throw some money down on
you know in the middle of the match and
suddenly you've got another perk
on your character so it's it's all stuff
that's kind of
incentivizing you to work together play
well
like exploring actually has this big
upshot
if you're trying to get better weapons
because like we got to the end
of act four in our run in just the alpha
and got completely demolished
a few times right so like there's
definitely a big incentive on
hunting around for money hunting around
for sometimes like you said you find
weapons that are like already decked out
with attachments
so you can just be like oh sweet ak-47
with laser sights
super good there's a really big
incentive on trying to balance between
whether you should just like sprint
through and try to stay alive or whether
you should
dedicate that time to looking for more
gear
and that i think adds a lot of
repellability too because
like if you can manage to get better
stuff it's almost like a battle royale
system
right where the better stuff you get to
the end the more chance you have of
surviving but then again the director
might be tuning it
to make you have a tougher challenge at
the end too if you're
super decked out originally i was a
little frustrated because i felt like
i wasn't finding the the variety of
weapons
um that i was used to in like left or
dead like i remember being like where's
the shotgun i really want a shotgun
like i love using shotguns and left for
dead um but it turned out
it was that i just needed to look more
like once we started like spending more
time like
properly exploring we did find more
weapons as you mentioned so i do think
uh this game like encourages more
exploration of the environment and it is
randomized as well like we had um
uh a door that had like a little like
symbol on it we're like oh what's that
and it turned out like we needed a lock
pick and we opened it up and it had
like a bunch of really good stuff in it
like a perk card and some weapons
um and then we died and we restarted
that section
and that door was just a yeah a door
that you couldn't open anymore so it's
like okay they
are kind of moving things around so you
you want to always be
like searching and looking for areas for
uh for new stuff
yeah and you can also tune your weapons
based on your deck
like you have a bunch of starting
starting weapon cards so like
if you want to put a deck or a card like
that in your deck you only have 15 slots
right but if you want to throw in like a
shotgun card or an ak-47 card
and risk not finding a weapon and
starting with one but you'll have like
one less perk
possibility basically so you can you
know customize a loadout when you go in
we should also note that um all the
characters seem to have
their own special perks and weapons as
well
so like i played one guy i think his
name's hoffman and he's
you know like a weekend warrior gun nut
kind of guy he starts with a pistol as
opposed to say a melee weapon as his
secondary
which is super useful because you find
pistol ammo just everywhere
and then his character perks um i think
it was
he has a chance of causing some enemies
to drop ammo when he kills them
right so other characters are like more
melee focused
or can move faster whatever they all are
a little different they're not like
drastically different so it's not like
uh you know if you pick a character that
you don't like you're you know gonna
you're gonna suffer
or anything like that but they do have
like these little extra abilities
that um that work toward the teamwork
aspect of it and give you like a little
bit of a different experience
so i mean we got a chance to look at the
game it's it's still an early
alpha we just got that one map so it's a
very brief slice of the game but
uh phil how do you overall feel about
how it's shaping up
yeah i'm i'm into it um you know like
this is a very small slice of the game
like you said it doesn't seem like there
are a lot of weapons or
necessarily other pieces in the game
yet that will probably be there in the
uh
in the total package we don't know what
the multiplayer is like stuff like that
but i have missed left 4 dead i realized
as i was playing this and this is really
you know it gets you back there real
really quickly and uh i'm into the the
little roguelike tweaks and the sort of
metagame ideas
it feels like a version of left 4 dead
that will keep you involved for a longer
period and be a little better about
you know uh making it so players can
sink a lot of time into it and still not
necessarily get bored with it
i'm interested in seeing where it goes
and uh i had a pretty good time
we faced off against some interesting
weirdo zombies
across the you know during the course of
it they're
similar to left 4 dead but not the same
there's a
a big giant monster you fight called an
ogre that you mostly just like run from
it's like 20 feet tall
all those aspects seem like cool
additions to
the underlying formula but it all feels
really familiar and i feel like i could
slip right back into it pretty easy all
right well thank you everybody for
watching uh this video talking about our
impressions of back for blood and if you
enjoyed this video make sure to click
subscribe
and hit that little bell so that you can
support us because it means a lot to us
and thank you so much for watching
thanks
[Music]
you